the left claim said it opposes racism by
now you know the left is always
projecting what they say you're doing is
what they're doing and they're
constantly fomenting racial hatred they
do it constantly whether it's by
publicizing fake hate crimes or in
stating racial quotas systems or
bringing back segregation sometimes it's
just their mindless coverage of news
stories this headline this is a real
headline of rants today in the
Washington Post we're quoting now whites
are mainly to blame for air pollution
but blacks and Hispanics bear the burden
says a new study it's too funny let's
just be clear though I mean take three
steps back this article was designed to
attack an entire group based solely on
their skin color the headline the
leading paragraphs are all meant to
attack this enemy racial group in our
midst and of course imply that they are
racist by doing what it doesn't say
doesn't matter they're hurting other
people this article doesn't seek to help
the environment if it was they could
talk about overall air pollution levels
which by the way and the post has even
reported this have declined dramatically
in the last few decades for everybody
because the factories closed the post
could have focused on the extra air
pollution caused by immigration driven
population growth or by wealthy people
jetting across the country to attend I
don't know climate conferences but they
didn't Jeff Bezos wouldn't like that
he's one of those people and the post
know that because it's his newspaper